this is a model of a cancerous tumor
each of the tiny dots represents a cell
and each color a different genetic
mutation as the cells reproduce the
tumor grows
modeling tumors is difficult cancers are
complicated and influenced by countless
processes like how cells grow and die
mutate and move this new model combines
these factors to create one of the most
comprehensive pictures to date
in this first version of the model the
tumor grows slowly as the cells in the
middle run out of space to divide into
but in the body tumor cells can move
here they're allowed to migrate
squeezing into surrounding tissues and
finding more space to fill
this causes the tumor to grow much more
quickly to make matters worse the
migrating cells take with them the most
successful mutations spreading them
across the tumor represented here by
large clumps of color
the researchers also modeled how the
tumour reacts to treatment in the future
models like this could help doctors
predict the effects of different
combinations of therapies as well as
understanding the resistance which leads
to tumors coming back so far the
researchers suggest that reducing cell
migration could be a new way to help
slow and control tumor growth
you